- Well, so now I'm out
here in the public, right?
I'm sitting in the middle of Balboa Park
and I'm perfectly at ease.
And when I was about 19,
I had anxiety attacks.
So I had a lot of anxiety and
I didn't wanna leave my house.
So I had a psychiatrist helping me,
and I didn't want to do it with drugs.
So he explains to me
that long-distance running is
a really good antidepressant,
and I needed one,
so I started becoming
a long-distance runner.
But he also suggested
that I learn to meditate.
So I was a long-distance
runner for a long time.
I ran a lot.
It really helped.
You know, I started being
able to get out and go places.
But then I started
meditating after a while.
I meditated so much,
I meditated at least
two or three hours a day
for maybe six or nine months,
that in my dreams I
started being able to see
what was gonna happen in the future.
You know, I didn't really
understand what was going on.
I literally also could tell
when my sister was gonna call me.
I could predict things.
I literally became psychic.
Like I, you know, didn't
know quite what was happening
'cause it wasn't predictable.
But I decided one day
to stop in at the Del Mar Racetrack.
I was going, "Wow, this is crazy."
And it was a Friday afternoon
and I drove to the Del Mar Racetrack,
and I sat there and I go,
"Which horse is gonna win?"
And I looked at the names
and I hid from myself
the odds for the horses.
And I can't remember
the name of the horse,
and I just said, "It's gonna be,"
- "Thormeister."
You know, some horse.
And I'm sitting there and the horse won,
and I'm going, "Oh my God."
And so then I did the
next race, and it won.
And I won like three races in a row,
which was, you know,
for what I was betting,
and I won a couple hundred dollars.
And I go, "Oh my God,
what's going on here?"
And so I went to the track,
I started leaving work early
when the track would open
so I could get there and start betting.
But then I became sort of crazed, like,
"I gotta get a lot of money, you know?
I'm gonna help all the kids
in the world and stuff."
And when I would get crazed
about it, I couldn't do it.
I had to relax and not care
if I really won or not.
So I did that for a couple of years
(laughs) and I won a lot of money.
But I decided that it
wasn't really that useful
because if I tried to get too much money,
it didn't seem to work.
But to this day,
the last time I went out
to one of the casinos,
sat there and listened for the horse races
and bet on it, I won.
Anyway, that's what
nobody would ever believe.
(light music)
- (Interviewee breathes deeply)
Hold on, let me ask my father
to go away so he doesn't hear it.
He doesn't know this either.
So I served overseas in Afghanistan
and I killed a teenager.
I can share it, like,
this is anonymous, right?
- [Thoraya] Well, no.
- Like, you won't know
my name or anything.
Like, if you can see
my face, I don't care.
- [Thoraya] It gets a lot of views though.
- That's fine.
If people pick me out, I'm
open to talking about it.
Like, unfortunately, it's
something I have to sort of
come to grips with as someone, you know,
who has that history.
It was like something of an ambush
and it was relatively close to me,
like sub-a hundred meters,
so you can actually like see it happening,
which is why it had a particular
impact on me, I guess.
Essentially, like, after,
I basically just laid there on the ground
just until he ultimately
just died there alone,
like in the sand at the
end, you know, with nobody.
(chuckles) Yeah, don't really know
much what more to say about that
without really like breaking down.
And it's definitely made me
a little bit disenfranchised
with like United States, the military,
especially since I joined the
military to get an education.
Like, what was the whole point?
It was in Afghanistan
and everyone knows how that turned out.
It's just like, do all
that, go through all that.
To sum it all up, I don't
feel very patriotic anymore.
That's the reality of the armed forces.
You're not really
protecting your government,
you're advancing the
interests of some politicians
who don't know what the they're doing.
So, you have any other questions
or prompts?
- [Thoraya] I do.
I have a couple more
questions if that's okay.
- Yeah, go ahead.
- [Thoraya] I've never come
across an answer like yours.
And I don't think it's 'cause other people
haven't been through it, but just because
people wouldn't wanna share it.
- Yeah, that's the same with me.
I'm actually putting in a special effort
to try and come to grips
with this kind of thing.
So, like, like it or not,
it's something I have to
eventually accept about myself
and the fact that stuff
like this is happening,
stuff like that around
the world, it's just,
I guess I try not to think
about it so you can live.
So you can actually live your
life and continue to function.
- [Thoraya] What's something
I wouldn't believe about you?
- So I feel like I've always come off
as a very positive person,
and I consider myself a very
positive, optimistic person.
I try to always view
things in a good light.
But in the past couple years
I have started to see the
world in a very negative way.
I don't wanna necessarily say cynical,
but very disappointing.
And there are moments where I
can see that there is light.
I can see there are such
good, wonderful people
and there is hope, but it's very hard
to kind of hold onto
that on a daily basis.
So I definitely have that deep inside me,
and I feel like a lot of people
wouldn't really realize that.
- [Thoraya] Did something specific happen
that made you have this
new viewpoint of the world?
- Yeah, so being that I'm Palestinian,
the big thing right now,
obviously, everything going on in Gaza,
that has been weighing on
me so incredibly heavily.
And it's very, very difficult to have hope
in the midst of that and
see any sort of light
when not only is this going on,
but it is allowed to go on
for over a hundred days at this point.
I've honestly lost count.
So that's been pretty heartbreaking.
- [Thoraya] Is your family okay in Palestine?
- Yeah, so my family's in
the West Bank, not in Gaza.
I visited them a few months
ago, and they are safe.
But, of course, we could tell
that they were very scared
but trying not to really show it.
Of course there's this constant fear
that my family won't be
safe for much longer.
So that has been really
difficult to deal with.
So it's hard.
- I think something that
you might not believe
is that I was homeless and,
yeah, I was really young,
but it was definitely
like a big part of my life
and not a lot of people know that.
But I didn't understand what was going on,
like, the situation fully,
but I understood the
social implications of it
and I decided to hide it
for a really long time
for like the people around
me and like my friend groups.
And it really like caused
a lot of damage doing that.
And after that I was able to kind of like
turn it into something really positive,
and like now I share it with people.
And like it made me a very grateful person
and a lot more humble,
I would say, definitely.
And like I obviously now understand
that you never know what
someone's going through.
You like actually never know.
And like a lot of people didn't
know for a really long time
what I was going through,
and it's really easy to put up a front.
So it's good to be like
open-minded about that.
- [Thoraya] What's something
I wouldn't believe about you?
- That I'm a princess.
- [Thoraya] Like, literally?
- Yeah.
- [Thoraya] You're a princess?
- I'm a princess.
- [Thoraya] Princess of where?
- I can say it's (indistinct),
that's how you say it.
- [Thoraya] What does it
feel like to be a princess?
- Honestly, because I grew up
in it, it's very normal, yeah.
- [Thoraya] What's life
like as a princess?
- Ooh, that's interesting.
I think like, if you think about it,
it depends on where you're from
and how they treat princesses.
Where I'm from, it's more like
we just have like certain obligations,
like we have to go to certain things
that is happening around town.
But other than that,
it's like pretty chill.
- [Thoraya] Do you like being a princess?
- I do, I do.
(both laugh)
- [Thoraya] What do you
want to say to the world
as the princess of where you're from?
- (laughs) Be you and just have fun,
and be kind to other people.
- [Thoraya] There you go.
- So, I mean, I look
like a soccer mom from,
you know, from Connecticut.
But I was an entertainment
reporter for 15 years.
I met everybody in the world.
I met Mick Jagger and Paul
McCartney and Ringo Starr
and Pavarotti and presidents.
I did a lot of theater as well.
And Steve Martin wrote a play
called Picasso at the Lapin Agile,
and he showcased it first
in Stanford, Connecticut.
And so the reporters were invited
to come and interview him.
And I had a really bad cold
and I was reluctant to go,
but I'm like, "I don't wanna
miss this opportunity."
So sure enough, I get
there, my cold is so bad,
I've gone through every
tissue I have in my car
in the drive down.
And somebody asked a question
and he rolled his eyes
and looked bored already.
And somebody else asked a question.
And I finally came up
with a question in my mind
that I thought wouldn't
offend him, and I rose my hand
and he rolled his eyes as it
to say, "What have you got?"
And when I went to ask the question,
a bubble booger came
out of my right nostril
and it was so big
that it looked like a Bazooka
Bubble championship bubble.
Like if I was in a
contest, I would've won.
But it didn't even pop,
it just kind of floated.
I mean, even if it randomly
happens when you have a cold
and you get a little bubble,
like it's a little thing
and it pops, right?
No, this thing like defied every law
of physics that there is.
And his eyebrow went up to his hairline
and he tightened his lips to
stop himself from laughing.
And I'm going, "Oh my God."
I'm looking down, he's looking at me.
And we were both kind of
on axis with each other,
so not everybody could see
what was (laughs) going on.
And I went like this,
which was the only thing
I could think of doing in that moment.
So now I have it's all over
my face, under my hand.
And I said, "How did you envision Picasso
and Einstein having a
conversation in a bar?"
And meanwhile I'm reaching down in my bag
to search for the only tissue
that I got, and I find it,
and it's a wet wad of wet tissue.
And he's talking and talking
and talking and smirking
and watching me do this whole thing
of trying to wipe my face off.
And I was literally dying, right?
Like, there was nothing I could do,
other than get up and
walk out of the room.
So now I got my face kind of over here
and, I mean, I was going for
the sleeve at this point,
'cause, what was I gonna do, right?
And so he keeps talking,
and other people would
try to get his attention
and he kept looking back at
me like, "What else you got?
What else you got?"
(both laugh)
And I was so mortified.
And my tape recorder was like
20 feet away in a mult box connected,
and so I couldn't even get
up and skulk out quietly
before the thing ended.
So the thing ends, I'm mortified.
He kept looking back at me multiple times.
I jump up, run, grab my
material, my equipment,
I shove it in my bag and
I go running for the door.
And I'm looking down and I look up
and, literally, he blocked my exit.
He wouldn't let me leave.
And he goes... (laughs)
And I'm like, "Are you
torturing me right now?
Are you really?"
And he goes, "No, I
just wanted to tell you,
that was the funniest thing
I've ever seen." (laughs)
So I'm like, "Okay."
And I literally had nowhere
to go, but I was right.
But the bubble booger
and Steve Martin remains.
That one will stay with
me past the dementia.
I'll still remember it.
- I'm 50, and I've had
four knee replacements.
- [Thoraya] Four?
- (laughs) The eyebrows went up, you see?
- [Thoraya] I'm not sure
if the hardest part of that
to believe was the knees
or the fact that you're 50.
- It's the 50, yeah, it's a combo.
- [Thoraya] You look so young.
- (laughs) I dig it.
- [Thoraya] Can you maybe share
what's been the hardest part of that?
- Oh, God.
I would say the hardest part
was for more than a year,
I really didn't walk more than, say,
a couple hundred steps a day.
I don't think most able-bodied
people really understand
what a gift it is to be mobile.
To walk, to skip, to hop.
To be able to get up from the
bed and walk to the bathroom,
and to be able to walk back.
Just these little simple things,
you know, simple things.
And if anything, at this end
of the journey, I'm filled.
Oh, I don't wanna start crying.
(light music)
Wow, I'm just filled with gratitude.
I'm filled with gratitude
for like today, you know?
This is the first time I've
been to the park to walk.
And the plan had been
to walk through museums.
And then when we got
out here to the piazza,
it was just like, "What a beautiful day."
Like, "Let's just sit in
the sun and stroll around."
I said, "Maybe this is
the part about being 50
is you realize all of the things
that you think are so important."
It really comes down to
just the simple things,
which, you know, the breath we take,
spending time with someone you love,
and the ability to get to and fro.
So that's the gift of these new knees
and turning 50, yeah.
(light music)